[Music]
hey guys it's MKBHD and welcome to
another mini rant video I want you to
take your phone out your pocket or off
your desk or whatever and tell me how
much battery left do you have left
really be honest my point is that while
we all enjoy the various improvements
our mobile devices have been making over
the past couple years like processor
speed and Graphics improvements you
can't deny the facts Battery Technology
just isn't keeping up at all let's put
it this way less than two years ago the
original Motorola Droid was released it
had an 800 megahertz single core
processor less than half a gig of RAM a
3.7 inch 854 by 480 LCD display and it's
half an inch thick it was a
groundbreaking and revolutionary device
I would know now 2011 enter the Samsung
Galaxy Note 1.5 gigahertz dual core
processor one gigabyte of ram a 5.3 inch
1280x800 OLED display and all that in
just 9.6 millimeters thin so from this
list you can see the specs have actually
gone up significantly processor clock
speed is 180 faster and has 200 hundred
percent of the course twice the course
the amount of ram has also more than
doubled so more than 200 percent the
number of sheer pixels on the display
has gone up nearly 250 percent and all
of this comes in a frame that's at just
70 percent of the thickness of the
original the droid's battery life about
a day the notes battery life
about a day I wish and I only wish
because I'm not an engineer yet but I
sincerely wish that we could come up
with some amazing new groundbreaking
Battery Technology the way we are in
other sorts of components and phones and
mobile devices now we know that there
are bigger batteries for bigger devices
in fact it's a 2500 milliamp hour in the
note but that's because it has more
power hungry radios more fast processor
needs more Graphics power you get the
point the screen everything takes up
more battery the point is the battery
needs to be better not bigger better I
just have a feeling you guys might agree
with that share this video with your
friends on Twitter and stuff you can
click to tweet below if you agree with
this rant or you could give it a thumbs
up it helps a lot and I appreciate it
anyway thank you for watching and thanks
for subscribing and I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]